i've been using the airpods 3 for over a  month now so today i'm going to talk  about everything that i discovered along  with why i stopped using my airpods pro  and instead started using the air pods  3. these things are extremely  comfortable even for somebody like me  that doesn't have any issues with the  airpods pro now there are two things  that most people don't talk about that  are exclusive to these new air pods the  first one is a skin sensor that replaces  the optical sensor and the next one is  the precision finding in the app now as  far as battery life these are also  incredible and a really big step up from  the air pods too biggest issue with the  air pods 3 is the sound leakage after a  month of use i have found that i really  enjoyed the airpods 3. i like the  smaller case i like the better battery  life i like the sound quality of it  overall this is the better product i  think this is a really good buy unless  you need active noise cancellation